all right gator
Gator oh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally
uh Florida city in Homestead
down south very southern tip
tell me about your family
oh wow man I got a crazy past ah
I I never had my mom and dad I had my
grandfather and grandmother raised me uh
we're spiritual people and uh we'd be
leaving the higher spirit
um my grandfather
started teaching me when I was five on
up and see uh to see and talked to uh
spirits
that I come through and uh
it wasn't easy but as I got over it it
got easier and uh he kind of had his she
Spirits talk Spears and uh listen to him
and uh actually Reach Out And Touch
touch the spirit
hey it's very difficult
how you have to reach out yeah they
tickle your the apartment
because
you know that they're there you know
they take you all over you feel these
little tickles spots going on yeah
and uh my grandmother at age 14 she she
taught me how to cook so yeah that was
connected with some sort of religion
yeah yeah and my grandmother and her
grandfather you know they did a lot of
spiritual energy they they had a native
in Dutch what religion was it yeah my
grandfather and grandmother was a Dutch
and they were more native
and Native side my grandfather was and
my grandmother was more a Dutch but but
they they had to mix they both had a
mixture of
both native and Dutch where were your
mom and dad where was where was your mom
and dad um my mom and dad were my dad
really he was uh he was a
sickle he was sick he was uh he had a
bad habit drinking uh we got raised on
the farm we had Gators uh uh Longhorn
steers uh African booze uh milking cows
and we had 400 American cows and uh my
father used to stay drunk all the time
and uh he he didn't he couldn't afford
to pee
for help help me to come in you know and
let us kids we were kids at the time and
go to go to school and learn something
you know we had a sneak away sometimes
we go go to school because how far did
you go in school I I went to ninth grade
I had a
I had two failures
in my life
and this is a reason
reading it right
I can read
now I can read I I assume so I mean you
know but there is a big words with all
the vowels and I still have trouble with
I can't write I can't write for nothing
you know uh what kind of work have you
done what kind of work have you done oh
man I can be I build houses I need brick
block
uh porschement the blacktop I I even
rebuilt a a digital truck motor
go to school I should grab a small
engine in BOCES there's a small engine
repair
and uh I worked for a track Trailer
Company
that they're called Google check Trailer
company and uh they had uh 26 doors they
drive in and out and I usually pulled
the trailers in and out
when they get done building them I
pulled one out and bring another one in
and I did that all day long and then
they switched me around to the to the
paint booth then I started paint spray
painting uh clear and I over these brand
new gas trailers they come in they're
aluminum so we had this really strong
clear that they use on Jets
they're because
the the aluminum that you know it's
sooner or later it loosens up it chips
and cracks but uh we're just uh Chrome
arm paint that they call
hammer and he I mean he hit that thing
about it six seven times and not a den
not a dent editor because of the street
coaster
clear I put that back to your childhood
what what was it like growing up with
your grandparents back to your childhood
what was it like growing up with your
grandparents um
my father and my father I I couldn't
deal with my father
Ah that's why I you know I I say I've
never had a father and mother my mother
he used to beat my mother
and uh
he used to take a
hey and uh beater and then rape her your
father yeah
so she ended up
moving away
and going with uh she met a right guy
down here she goes to Hudson New York
Zoomer and uh she ended up going back
forward back and forth with him
and uh she used to come out to the farm
house you know and kidnapped us as kids
and we we get away for about a month or
two before my father find us you know he
had somebody else out looking for us
now he wasn't carry he wasn't a kind guy
or terrible uh uh
he wasn't a good father you know how do
you treat you
ah
uh we never got along yeah he he used to
be able to
uh
it's called a cow strap a milk machine
strap and it goes across the cow's back
and it has a his black strats and it had
a bunch of holes in it with brass rings
in it
now the other end has a long hook a
metal hook that hooks up underneath and
it hooks into the strap then you put the
milk machine on it and that it holds uh
that the milk machine and it used to be
a whack us with that at least your
school rubber hose
marks on on their backs and calf straps
and cat's tails they come out of the
swamps and uh yeah and back then the
child abuse
with nothing
didn't even have the word
meaning didn't even have a meaning to it
abuse
yeah anything that you got from your
parents you must have deserved
you know or they did it for pleasure and
they still got away with it he
he's not I thought it murdered
murdered my brother
hurts
and he got he got away with it
here I'm gonna a piece of string
down to me around that comes off the
bell I hate he chewed over to
pipe
in in the barn
and they found it down down
swinging back and forth because the air
was blowing and
I don't know why but he he I don't know
how
he got a waivered
I used to have a
bad dreams
and uh
I turn around
I was talking in my sleeps I was talking
to my brother
the spirit was set free
he was he wasn't a guilty party
if he set free to to uh
they wouldn't do his life with the free
spirits and how old was your brother he
was 15
and your dad hung him and uh your dad
hung him well I had uh there's three
boys three girls your dad hung your
brother
sounds like uh well I remember I meant I
I I I was in and out all the time
because uh I I me and my father we've
never seen eye to eye after getting
ripped
and beaten to me
so many times
uh
which is a I just walked away
I couldn't I couldn't I couldn't deal
with it anymore
I went to the uh
Sheriff's Department
and uh
after
five years after my brother passed away
I I had bad dreams
my
my brother was
cool
call me by my name
trying to reach out
and somebody help him
yeah
I can do it
I didn't know what to do
but uh
I wanted to kill my father
so bad
but I never did I made threats but
David I was warned I was warned to stay
away you know you're not allowed so many
feet or miles from from him and you just
uh
it was a painful thing it was very very
painful I never knew I would have to go
through
seeing something like that in my in my
my family I I felt it something weird
and strange coming in
from the spirits that report never let
me know that there was something
happening going to happen but I
I still learning from my grandfather
that what the spirit is going to do for
you and I hope they can help you that
they're here to guide you into a better
way you know they're not here to hurt
you but you got
so many different spirits
where I stay now over in uh Manchester
and West and Western Ave in a retirement
home place did not retired that was for
uh people over 65 or well I'm not 65 but
there's younger people there and it's
it's it it's too much hate in that
building I can feel it I it was nice
then I can't stay there I I go out in
the streets
then until the Daybreak I mean I have to
watch him a a fold up cardboard
bit box and it's not a cardboard but
it's you put your clothes in it and it
has a zipper top I think
I watched a move
back and forth wow man what's going on
here and I've been freaking out and the
lady upstairs she's making all kinds of
noise
we've got some kind of Voodoo or
something
you know hey
I don't know I I I had a
I got a cousin he works for the sheriff
department he gave me a little monitor
and it was monitors that the monitors
you're running across the ceiling you
walk back and forth into in the
apartment and of course and you walk
across the ceiling
and you find a a microphone or a speaker
or something that they plan into the
floor
and listen to your conversation while
you're on the phone while you're in
whatever in your opponent you you don't
even know that they're doing it but I
can feel it I feel this is
the spirits are telling me that there's
something happening
and I told him
but they let them grow they didn't they
didn't go and arrest them they didn't
they gave them a warning
you know that you're breaking the law by
what is it uh
you're breaking uh
I forgot what they said but when did you
come to Los Angeles
uh
I don't know I get lost here I assuming
I got to think he thinks it's too fast
think it's too too hard uh I got a plate
in my head I got beat in the head with a
bumper Jack yo bumper Jack and the one
the handle the one lug nut
I got beat in the head five times from a
crackheads
they uh
heard me talking about and uh painting
my sister's bar I painted it like three
times because it was it was uh Oakwood
and I painted I'd say you had painted
inside for three times and she gave me
eight hundred dollars
and uh they thought I had 800 on me I
only had 23 dollars
we was at a party we had another party
and they were hiding in the garage
doing everything or whatever
and I didn't drink I drink I would use
and and you know and I didn't smoke I
don't smoke I don't smoke or drink still
I gave it up a long long time ago
um what are you doing here on Skid Row
what are you doing here on Skid Row
uh
if you don't smoke or drink if you don't
smoke or drink all right what are you
doing down here
I uh
I live life like life is more believe
you know free opening in in
spiritually uh
they're uh respectively treat and treat
your body like it's supposed to be
treated don't abuse it you know in your
mind I mean I gotta think of a plate in
my head I gotta take these pills
and then I say two pills is a Cymbalta
and the abilifier
there's a motor helps me
think uh uh more wisely uh more and it
opens my mind up and it runs free in the
in the uh the beautifier it stops me
from having seizures heart attacks
strokes and all that
from the Pew because it's so powerful
you know
have you been in love before have you
been in love before uh two relationships
uh
both of them were bartenders uh and they
um
I had a daughter Andrew Lee
uh
Jesus about 28 38 now
I have a son
they could even call him a gator III uh
he's a 22-23
um he he is a different one
my my first
girlfriend was a bartender she was uh
she she was a Rowdy and she that's her
daughter our daughter and the second
girl was a stripper and she quit doing
the stripper and then she was yeah nine
years later I meet her in the same bar
how did I make the first one
and we we went out for that two and a
half about two and a half years
but I I was going to get along with her
mother she was she was crazy yeah she
attacked me one time and kicking her
nails and trying to dig my face all up
and I had to push it away
and
then the cops girl came and oh man it
was crazy it was it was a scene that
Beyond this
yeah I don't know how to say that it's
exactly right but
my best part of life was wrestling
gators wrestling gators yeah National
engagers
I got a uh two missing finger tips I got
a call Mark here I got a call Mark here
and I I got another one right here
underneath here how big are these
alligators how big are they I wrestled
with a 24-foot gator
but they're heavy and they're slow
you get the eight and ten nine ten foot
they're worse than uh
I don't think I can I think there's
anything here I said that a little bit
of water and and and the bottom of like
a swimming pool
and then they get the fastest dude like
a
lizards if you see them running through
the desert yeah they'd be boogie man
why you wrestle a gator huh why do you
wrestle an alligator
is a
it seems like it would be fun
because I seen it done and uh
his fear is fearful and it is a
different kind of fearful you got to go
against and you're going like you're
going again going against a creature is
uh
then Barbarian for years many many years
years Gators and alligators it's like
fighting a dinosaur yeah you're dying a
dinosaur yeah what's the goal to pin it
down so it can't no no yeah depending on
you have people watching this stuff and
then yeah you really grabbed by the tail
and you you swing them around and you uh
you roam over you pin them you rub your
belly you roll them around the back you
rub your belly and then go to sleep
yeah uh I gotta uh I was doing a
demonstration for uh
a group of people in uh I I was on TV I
wasn't really on TV I called Gator Boys
in Florida
hey they might have changed all that now
but different things but it's been years
since I didn't but I took an uh uh how
to get her mouth open
and I put my I put my head I put my head
in The Navigators
into the Gator's mouth I was doing good
then all of a sudden
I started sweating
the one that I swear
I had sweat come off my forehead
run down my Statler nose and she just
hit my nose and then bam I hit the
Gator's tongue and he went ah like that
he lost on my head
I thought it was that was it and she got
eight people
for it to hold the gator that down so it
wouldn't do the death row
toward the open up his mouth I hold his
mouth you know they have pickaxes they
had shovels that hammers a hammer handle
and uh
I took another 20 minutes 20s about 30
minutes did get his mouth open man I had
headaches for four to five months I had
imprints
in this time my head my face
and the people oh man that hurt I
twisted my neck I broke my neck and he
broke my neck on it
and
I I broke my neck twice as long and once
with the gator though and uh he he'd be
pissed off
I mean he was uh about a 12-footer
and he was he was ready to rip me apart
and it don't take much for you for a
gator because they got the the the the
healthy and the all-in-one unit and
they're fluffed and he could he could
take your hand and it would leave him so
quick it had faster than uh chainsaw or
somebody's really in the next uh a
machete he can be traced as fast
I just needed I seen people get hurt
he I just wrestling man I got hit by the
tail
to me 70 feet in the air
the terrorists I come down and then my
ankles and this one here
if they were to join us
I broke it and this is a this is the
worst one I got six pins in there and
three of them are broken
and it's right across the front and man
that hurts this one here I got stick
pins in it but none of them are broken
because they broke it in a different way
I come down a different ways
and
uh
I I tell you I had a lot of money in my
work with a carnival
a carnival man I had a 14 when I went
away with the carnival
and that's where I joined up with the
investment Gators you get a kind of a
community to show people how to wrestle
Gators and stuff
and uh I was uh
a game guy first I show dimes and dishes
every maybe uh
whatever the down there and then that's
tradition or a glass or cooked in the
shot glass or whatever you you that's
what you went and I did that for 10
years
made good money I made 10 out of a
dollar
instead of 10 10 but out of a dollar
twenty dollars worth of Dimes they make
you dollars for themselves
they'll Yeah the more times you sell the
more money you make
and uh I did that for uh 10 years and I
became the foreman
then my boss passed away and one of the
brothers and uh
I wanted to try something new I went to
the rides
and I I ran a I became a foreman after
being on the rides for about
five months I became informing of the
flying barbs
and the Swiss bars the flying Vibes the
cars they look like a a sled that you
pull behind a horse in the snow
you know there's a horse proposal today
the the street bobs it's a five-man car
that you push down the ice
that it's down the Chutes and if other
guys are pushing it and they jump in it
and they shoot down through the shoots
yeah that's pretty good but everybody
like an orbit around it was so loud man
you couldn't even hear the music I don't
care how how loud you play music you're
going to hear it it was worse than the
train coming through what was the best
time of your life what was the best time
of your life what's your favorite memory
uh my best way to tell me the life will
be in the carnival and the restaurant
Gators but the Gators the rest of the
Gators
I really like that job
advocated uh they made you think well
more wisely and more more wildly you
were an Entertainer you were an
Entertainer yeah yeah
I I I equal a gator tail
and it's 30 minutes I you take it and
you lay down to the last two pieces of
skin then you then you then you uh you
give it a decision I had both ends you
cut it and you cut it down the middle
you use garlic butter
and lemon
and you wrap it up in an aluminum foil
and wax paper
excuse me then you put it into a pretty
steamer
you steam it
now if you cook it any other way fry it
boil it bake it
all that yeah it tastes like chicken
if I'm on chicken I go give me a chicken
it tastes like chicken this is the way
the meat was you know and if you steam
it man you you have the best skater did
anything you ever have yeah you walk out
of there with a smile
dinner
Oceanside
when I got here
and I was at the uh
uh Social Security building and I was
talking to a security guard
and the security guard had asked me hey
Gator how come they call you gator and I
showed them Edition this and that and
they turn around and they
said I told him that you know uh
so they hey we're getting Partners she
smashing back he's one another hey they
come out with some bruises and then they
look like you've been in a very big
Tango bar fight or something and uh I
told him what you do is you go go find
your place
it's so Gators beat and uh he went to a
priest he said as a sports it's a sports
team where you go ahead and get the all
your sports stuff and it has a little
canal running and this and this and that
and the show gated me and he took his
wife and his two kids he said he went
there and he bought he he told the cook
as soon as I said the best way to do it
man
let him know you don't want to try a big
boom boom uh garbage dip you might you
might have steamed came in and show you
to cook now the wager is that the wages
didn't know what they just didn't know
what to think
and they come back the next day and say
Gator guess what we went and had a gator
meat
we took you we took yeah your word on
how to make it you know this and that
they said they came out
and they came out and the owner came out
and said
you know where'd you hear this from it
was yeah I met a friend name is Gator
he's your professor alligators and uh he
told us how he told us that the best way
to this cookie that the meat is is a
cement and that's what they did 20
minutes you get the best play this Gator
meat you ever had you can eat it like
stew almost you know you don't even have
to cook Gator meat
he's eating raw yeah why
do you have any vices
Gator do you have any vices like you
don't drink you don't smoke
I I have a drink don't smoke nope
I don't I don't need to I used to
I I I I I don't know it's something
it didn't meet up in
here in in their lungs and
I thought it was nasty after I got after
I quit
I smoke cigars that's huge exactly
and I didn't just like everybody else in
the world these days but one day at my
birthday
how do you cook cold turkey I didn't
mean to program or nothing I didn't need
help here I got all these people trying
to do with other people some people are
doing it some people don't you know it's
on the planet the way the game goes it's
all in the positives which way you think
and which way you don't
do you have any regrets in your life
regression regrets ah
man
I got a regression getting your father
you know and my mother I remember my
mother's fault but she should have never
left
she should never avoided abandoning
those kids where
ugly father we had you know I kept us
home for school I never went very much
school you know yeah and we went to
school we come home we're getting ass
whipping we have a rubber hose Alex
machine
and we had bruises all up and down their
bodies go to school showed a nurse but
you must have deserved it
yeah and uh
I just went on and on and I just drove
me away
and uh I think I feel really bad for
what happened to our family
never even appointed
a part of life then out of that part of
the family
I wish I was somebody else's family
that people I see other people we used
to go to school
could frames you around your bottom of
your boots because you never had a
chance to clean up or get ready for
school or change your clothes
here you go to school smelling like
house Cowboy like a farm they walk
around with a cow pasture all around
your boots and shoes
gay call names
I used to as you fight
a lot in school and you know to
try to
be somebody you know and prove a point
it's just about it's just it's just
Farmers that feed you
and your family
if your dad doing the farm work and any
kind of farm work the crop uh you know
the
listening tonight whatever I put picking
apples or you're picking corn or you
know
that's that's the thing but
there's my my destination was
the carnival
because I did that for 32 years
I broke my back of the on the flying box
eight eight feet up in the air pouring
down rain
and we go out in these little thin
borders like this all the way to the
outside to the end and we have a rope
just one guy on one pole one with it on
the other reported scenery up we hook it
he was running out of his slip he
couldn't hang on to it that I tried to
hang out in my
someone was the senior year
in the light bulbs I I did the best I
could in book there I went I come down
and then across
some blue steel it was on the ground
and I got up and walked away
about about three four days later I was
laying down in my bug truck where where
I stayed at and I I did the wrong
body turned in the bed and man I locked
up
I ever
saw with bad
I couldn't I couldn't take the pain and
three operations
uh three staff infections
uh I wanted
to do something about it but I couldn't
do nothing about it because I they had
me strung out on pills like in Miami
I wanted to shoot a hospital
I said
how how am I going to get staph
infection
from a hospital
dirty news or something something went
wrong I don't know I know I could never
that nobody would even tell me nothing
nobody would help me
do you try to accomplish something and
to win maybe something out of out of
something
they give me a
68 000. 60 68 hundred dollars
yeah if you call that money yeah broken
back I got four
four rides in my back
two years ago all the way up to my neck
uh I got
no tailbone
I have
I I had trouble walking
because of the nerves uh I ride the bike
better and walk
you're gonna I'm sitting down in the
seat and my body's not all on my feet
but out here
man I'd be walking and my feet they feel
like
they're on fire
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life what
would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
uh
um
I'm wrong I didn't really uh you know
somebody's some of those things I
I I try to think of more to get
something
do something right and go afternoon or
this and then and then all of a sudden
boom
it's Fall Apart
and that's right or something
I I was I was let me know what you're
hearing in the 51st 54th and I've been
on uh Avalon and uh my landlord
his father
yeah when I first moved in I've been
there for nine years hey we got it all
good and his father his wife passed away
then he caught old man's disease and uh
he finally passed away and his son took
over
and it started maybe he had a some kind
of attitude problem or something and he
he broke him and broke it gave the guy
upstairs what was happening broke my uh
a bedroom window in and two bugs in my
in my in my in my house into the carpet
took me a two three four months before
they they adapted before I knew it I
couldn't do nothing about it they they
read me up alive